the Joe Rogan experience well soon we're
gonna have war in space Rory I don't
know if you've been paying attention to
the news some Goods of Elon Air Force
guy was saying that we have to prepare
for the possibility of war in space but
this is an inevitable inevitable
possibility probably with drones well
let me ask you this what was your what
was your take on that UFO thing what is
this change space this was a UK ad for a
beer it's all these astronauts in space
there in space drinking beer the car my
god wait there's British astronaut I had
no idea belong beer wow that's cool
british astronaut
what would member that UFO thing that
happened like two months ago and they
released the government was like we have
no idea what this object is and you
heard the pilot in the air like what the
[ __ ] is that
I came across that remember like they're
like the UFOs it happened right after
Tom DeLonge was on here watch it did we
watch the government literally confirmed
that they don't know what it is and it's
a UFO and it's doing things and then
whatever would just stop talking about
wait a minute particularly I don't
believe these things enough I barely pay
attention they come my way and this was
on like real news sites right but what
is the video can we see the video again
there to see it again
Oh see stop hold on
this is but now remember this says has
been debunked you know you know yeah you
know who debunked it what's-his-face
Mick West Mick west from Medibank calm
what they did was they changed the
perspective from 1 X 2 to X so when see
when you're looking at something zoomed
in things move faster your sight picture
is much quicker when you're at normal
your sight picture slower so like as you
zoom in everything looks faster so when
the thing moved out of frame so fast it
was because it had been zoomed in all
not because it took off at some insane
other words the pilot was just [ __ ]
with the government no they didn't know
any better when whoever released the
video didn't look at it these meta bunk
guys looked at the video and you can see
all the numbers on the screen when you
look at the video you see like what his
perspective is x1 x2 and he points out a
look here it goes to x2
and then it just moves out of frame it's
not even that you're snapping in on it
you're looking at it from a totally
different perspective now you're looking
at it from a zoomed in perspective
that's interesting yeah see if you could
find a written question it sure my dream
was that it was gonna be aliens and
their goal was they needed plastic he's
got a bunch of photos in it see if you
find the photos he points him out that's
what I was hoping and they were gonna go
like our planet its plastic do you have
anything like we have so much yes in the
ocean you can just take it all you know
and then they just cleaned it all up and
things got better
mmm like they went to the Pacific
Garbage Patch and just like and then
they left mmm the Pacific Garbage Patch
you see there's a kid who's got a
solution to that what his young man and
figured out a solution god damn it I'm
supposed to be in contact with that
fellow now that I'd be curious to know
what that solution is some sort of a
machine that like skims the the ocean
for plastic and it collects all the
plastic huh yeah and I don't know what
what what it's powered by I think I want
to say it's powered it's a solar powered
thing that was the concept behind got
like a Roomba
Dutch students giant ocean cleanup
machine is going into production
inventor says the technology will solve
the marine plastic crisis but some
scientists are skeptical as they should
be there are scientists
Boyan slavich's that's right I was
connected to him how much it's growing
by let me write it down 8 million tons a
year
that's insane hi spells last name that's
la T plastic yeah well million we never
thought about we thought once we throw
it away
oh it's thrown away yes they've got it
no [ __ ] falls off there's there's
[ __ ] dumps they leave it sitting
there for supply to the dump they pick
it up they fly away with it but I don't
know the craziest thing is how like the
ocean currents all lead to one place you
know it's so weird it's weird that you
could see it all swirling and it's like
the size of Texas I think they said and
they say it breaks down all that
particles or all the the rather plastic
these weird little particles and the fit
and that's why they're pulling fish out
with mmm stomachs full of plastic you
fish out with it and more birds birds
are dying and they're feeding it to
their kids
and there they find babies in the nest
that have these plastic caps yeah filled
in their stomach it's really a horrible
horrible have you seen that do the stars
re balloon oh yeah is that really what
they saw what this says stops website
um-hmm well it might be that you say
they were tracking a party balloon in an
f-16 is that what it's supposed to be
saying yeah on the other website said
that exactly what you were describing as
I was reading it like the camera angles
were off and you can follow the angle
with the clouds with the yeah well once
you zoom in on something that's what
happens I mean if you if you've ever
looked through a binocular if you're
trying to hold a binocular the more
powerful the binoculars are the more
like the picture at the end seem shaky
it's a known you're known to take a
picture I think it's it's a cop it's not
an optical zoom it's a digital exactly
yeah so that was the explanation for the
bizarre behavior of that object
apparently it is so funny to me that it
was a party balloon what's that Jamie
there's another one too that was this
was the day before he posted which a
second video similarly I don't know if
this was the one that they were one dude
nobody wants you opposed to be more real
than me that's why I was asking you
about it nobody but I'm also I don't I
don't buy a lot of the thinking that
goes behind these things because people
just want to think that it's real they
want to think it's real so bad that they
they're not looking at it completely
objectively if it is real we got to know
for sure and there's no way you know for
sure this way this just doesn't seem
like we know for sure this seems more
like what he's saying is correct if they
if you see the perspective shift and you
see the the way the thing moves shift
but this is what we're talking about
earlier about like the government and
conspiracy like that's a perfect example
the government's like we have no idea
what this is that we're confirming it
was a UFO and then guys who arted the
government like yeah it's a [ __ ]
balloon douche Jamie scroll back down
what was it saying there this little
animation it says the flare around the
much closer engines rotate independently
of the rotation of the plane what does
that mean
I'm not I'm not sure I get this I think
we're we're halfway in the middle of
this page that's part of the problem
they're explaining something long and
drawn-out yeah see there's a lot of
these things that have been proven to be
horseshit and people see the video
footage and they think oh my god it's
UFL oh no it turns out it's a oil thing
that's on fire in the distance like
there's a lot of weird things that you
see in these like real blurry infrared
scans of [ __ ] or whatever that is
night-vision scans yeah I want to see
some real [ __ ] where you look at it and
you go okay
yeah device it if that's going to
[ __ ] UFO like what is that
but is that real and if someone says
that there's no way they could have
faked that then then I'm curious but
right now I just think too many people
want it to be real but for the Pentagon
the Pentagon sat on that for 10 years
and then released it and no one in the
Pentagon figured it out until I could
got out into the private sector online
and something's like it's a balloon and
you zoomed in on it you [ __ ] idiots
look it's this 2x that's my point about
government conspiracies I'm like yeah it
just seems like incompetence to me it
could be like nobody looked at that
closer but you had known for 10 years
that's just the people that were
responsible for that that were
incompetent do you think that you would
give the [ __ ] UFO searching job to
anyone you wanted to do real [ __ ] the
UFO searching job is a job as gift to
your friend's cousin that's fair you get
him a job you are going to be involved
in a top-secret operation
what Kowski get in here we're gonna be
searching for you we're gonna rely on
you you've been carefully selected
remember spies like that stupid dude to
interview people in their farms and
share their own moonshine and crystal
meth I'm sorry I saw it it was lit up
like a goddamn pale
[Applause]